so what makes more money over the border
now drugs or people
what's his job exactly what ages of
people he's asking well how can a parent
give up their child just to anybody
and let their child go alone what is the
hardest part of the job
what kind of money is in it what's up
with sex trafficking right now
he says what all these bracelets here
put on the on the people so they're
they're able to track them where they're
headed to
where they're going down the pipeline if
they could kill you they could beat you
they charge you a fine what they're
trying to tell these people
you're not gonna do anything without my
permission he said that the police are
mixed up with the cartels
good afternoon guys well i got quite a
video coming to you
in just a couple minutes time i'm gonna
meet someone
that works independently as a contractor
under a cartel
and if i seem a bit relaxed it's because
we were going to do it in mexico
now we're doing it here in mcallen i
have to have my
phone shut off we have to meet in a
public place
and what are we going to get into well
it's not just happening below the border
here human trafficking is happening
in the states and so when migrants come
over
there's a whole network there's a whole
business model there's a whole industry
and that's what we're going to learn
about very soon
and i'm going to see how far i don't
want to press boundaries but i'm going
to see how much information i can get
about this
let's call it industry that really
none of us know about should be
interesting
okay let's do this i was driven to a
location unknown to me
my phone was shut off the name i called
the trafficker tony
is not his real name his face was
covered in his voice altered for this
video
alright guys
here we are and
raul he's going to translate
and this is tony and i think we just
want to start it off by like
what is what does tony do exactly yeah
this is acceptable to tony
okay basically what he's saying his job
is he's an independent
you can say contractor that gets paid by
by the cartel to bring people
they bring people across into into texas
once they get to their destination
houston
it's up to them where they go or what
they do okay so
but he he also said that he works very
different from everybody else
he does get peed for what he does okay
he says i
i do to help out people out even though
i do get paid
and and i my job is to get them to
wherever they're trying to go
who who are his clients right now
basically what he's saying is that he
prefers to work with uh hispanic
with mexicans instead of people from
other countries
and the reason why he prefers to work
with them with mexicans that are trying
to come into the united states instead
of people from
other countries and for the simple
reason that
a lot of times they they don't pay
or they have problems uh with them
wanting it to their final destination
and stuff like that
so he prefers to work with uh mexican or
people from mexico
okay so when i can you explain the term
human trafficker because i think of
something uh
i think is something terrible right like
it's is it basically just you
you take money from someone's paying you
directly
and you're getting them from point a to
point b is that
basically he could work either here in
the valley or work in the laredo area
even though it might belong to somebody
else since he's an independent
contractor you can work for anybody with
any different cartel or whoever's
willing to pay him to do something
so the car the cartel contracts him
yes okay and they say tony we need
what like one person a van of people how
does it how does this work
he rather you rather do from five to
eight people at a time he does not like
doing a bunch of people at one time
that way he didn't get heat in the long
run or get you know what
too much draw too much attention where
they start watching him whether it's the
government from here or the government
from mexico or
or just somebody in general so most
people think when they think trafficking
at least i did i thought it
it only happened mostly below the border
but you is does tony say there's a lot
going on in in the us
right now el penta
[Music]
he's saying he's saying that he cannot
judge anybody
for wanting to come to the united states
okay but
all these people they're coming from all
these other countries to the united
states
they're drawing they're drawing
attention to him and his job
they're drawing heat to him and his job
because they're
they're creating too much attention for
example with the media with the
mexican military the united states
military the
the just border patrol in general
so like i said he can't judge anyone
they could come over here
because they're being allowed to but
like that it does
make his job harder what's his job
exactly does he drive
he picks up people in one location
drives them himself
to the endpoint
okay basically what he's saying his job
is to transport people once they get up
the river
whoever's holding them off the river and
there's no more
border patrol anybody else around he'll
pick him up
he'll bring him back to whatever
location once you bring him to location
he'll feed him give him clothing
whatever they need
meanwhile he's waiting for the other
transportation to get to
pick up these people whether it's to
take them to laredo
from radio they go up north or if it's
to take them here in the valley
uh whether it's just take them up north
directly from whatever location they're
at
and that's it basically he's the
middleman between the between the valley
and the rest of the united states
what age is it people all ages
is
basically the age they deal with is from
16 to maybe about 60 70 years old
he has gotten old people before uh he
has gotten sick people before
and they have gone into their
destination weather
so but his his thing is is not back to
the
the flux that's happening right now with
with the unaccompanied miners and stuff
because as we've discussed those get
those
roam freely after they get to border
patrol yeah but these are the other
people that don't want to get caught
yeah because they've been they're
mexicans yes right now there's a policy
other than mexicans can be led into an
asylum right now there's a hundred day
uh policy said by biden when he took
over
saying a hunt for our first hundred days
is no deportation
for other than mexicans or otms for
other than mexicans
so like i said his job is to get those
mexicans that want to come in
so this policy is good for his business
right now
in a way yes but like he said it creates
the
the attention where you have more people
more equipment more
everything that hinders him from doing
his job god she got you
so why does he do it
porque
it's a job to him because there's a huge
influx the last few months
what is what does he think about that
what's going on
what he's saying is that you know what
he's no one to judge that like he said
people
come to the united states but at the end
of the day they're saying they're
fleeing their country because of
violence and all this stuff
what if they're fleeing their their
country due to violence
he's asking well how can a parent give
up their child just to anybody
and let their child go alone make their
journey from south america to the united
states
he's saying you're taking the risk of
something happening to your child
whether they're being kidnapped or raped
or
yeah or something happened to them
drowning in the river or something
because you don't know so how can people
use it that excuse say hey
i'm leaving my country or i'm doing this
for this reason uh um
does tony having any kids
he has five kids okay and what does he
think about the
border and customs protection right now
[Music]
uh
okay what he's saying you know what that
he praises border patrol and everybody
for doing their job they're doing an
excellent job
that that's coming from him he likes
them yes
he has nothing against him you know what
they're doing they're they're doing
their job they're not his enemies
they're not
so he's saying they're doing a great job
and everything but at the end of the day
it's not only border patrol's problem
these people that are coming
to the united states otms other than
mexican
they're causing problems all throughout
their country while traveling this way
causing problems all through mexico and
he's glad that the united states had
stopped
those people from coming this way which
is back with the entire prior
administration
even though his business model is taking
migrants
and moving them into the answer to that
is yes and the reason why it's yes to
that is because like he said
his main his main thing is to bring
mexicans into the united states or
mexican people
okay into the united states okay gotcha
we can turn around guys we'll just go
back
uh all right take two
i'll just be over here so
what is um what is the hardest part of
the job
the hardest job he's done in his job is
actually
walking the people past the checkpoint
through the brush and stuff like that
he's done the smuggling part also he's
done different parts
of this uh this job that he does
what kind of what kind of money is in it
as far as what they pay or what he gets
paid yeah if he can disclose or just
give
us a rough estimate of what's possible
what's possible well what part though
what what they pay them or what they pay
him
both i would like both
right now what they're charging is
probably half of what everybody else is
charging
normally char they cros they charge
around 3 000 to cross
just the river itself they're charging
about a thousand five hundred
they're charging half the price of what
everybody else is charging
[Music]
okay it's they're charging uh by
like i said so much across the river so
much to char
they're charging so much to go from here
to to laredo so much from laredo to
houston for example
they charge it in pieces that's the
reason why just a thousand five hundred
it's just across the river
how does how does a mexican family that
doesn't have much money afford all all
of this their family in the states
sending them
[Music]
okay what he's saying that he can't tell
you for sure what people do
whether they sell their stuff or
whatever that's okay
something he can't answer what he is
saying is
how they charge by parts they don't give
the whole money up front
okay they're giving their words and you
know what we'll get you from here to
here here to here here to here
the families of the families from up
north are usually the ones who put in
the money for the people that are in
mexico trying to come this way
usually the people that that are that
are in transit you put it that way the
people that are in transit
they usually carry a few dollars on them
with them for whatever
they might want or need along the way
okay what it
does um does he does he think there's
anything
uh wrong with what he does or does he
feel like he's doing a good thing for
people
he said he said him he's doing it
to help out people here in the united
states we might look at him as doing
something wrong because he is receiving
money
okay he won't if i don't if i don't do
it someone else is going to do it either
way
okay the thing is you know what going
through me
it's a lot cheaper than going through
someone else plus they're
they're actually gonna do the job and do
what what they tell you they're gonna do
other people might uh kidnap you or
something hold you for ransom
they don't do that kind of stuff what's
up with
sex trafficking right now he says he
can't talk and represent because he does
not do that stuff
so since he's in the in the business he
knows what's going on
what right now like what percentage of
people coming over are
treated in a good way and what
percentage of people over are getting
into like
terrible situations like sex trafficking
or
in two opinions
different stories and stuff he could
only tell you about stories he's heard
not anything they've done but where
someone said you know what we'll
we'll take you across and stuff they
charge x amount of dollars
they wound up raping those females or
kids or whoever was there
and then they just wound up leaving them
in the middle of the brush somewhere
that was it
so there are stories of stuff that
happens and stuff
but he's saying you know what with him
and his crew and his people
that all they don't do that kind of
stuff okay
because at the end of the day that's
what brings the money their their
families they say you know what
these people could do it these people
could help you out these people will
bring you in
right they're cheaper or whatever okay
what were okay what were the
you didn't tell me because i told you to
tell me on camera when we got out of the
car
you showed me these uh bracelets anklet
things
or ankle bracelet things actually
there's some bracelets here
i'll have him explain what they are yeah
what are they basically these are
bracelets that they put on
the legal aliens they're different
colors there's yellow ones there's bold
ones there's red ones there blue ones
every organization has their own
bracelet and what it stands for
okay now i'll let him explain what it's
for pacquiao
estos
he says what all these bracelets here
put on the on the people
that they mean something they all have a
number i can't show you that number
because they don't know where it came
from yeah that number is written
basically in a log
with all that immigrants information and
stuff so they're they're able to track
them
where they're headed to where they're
going down the pipeline
the migrants have to keep that on on
them at all times
what's happening basically once the
people get to mexico
they'll say i guess
a smuggler in mexico they brought
somebody to reynosa for example
okay roanosa is the city right on the
border yes it's it's a border town right
here right across from mcallen mission
far so what happens they got a call and
say you know what i got five people
i need to bring them down to the river
so we could cross them into the united
states
so from there this place
okay what happens they send somebody to
to meet up with that person that
smuggler
that way they could be able to pay what
they're going to pay to to put them
or to give them attention or whatever to
to acknowledge that they want to move
somebody across
the way they were doing it they were
they were giving you basically
a free pass they like they smuggled uh
on a mexican
a mexican resident into into the united
states okay
if they got caught they get thrown back
as long as they had this bracelet on
like
and the number coincides with with their
books and stuff they were able to
get another chance for free he doesn't
think they're doing that anymore now if
you get caught
they're going to recharge you again
whatever they're charging you to to
bring you across again
um so before they used to give you
basically an insurance policy
saying hey you got another free shot if
you get caught you got another free shot
now the way he thinks it is that you
don't
came out significant okay basically what
this says is that you've already
reported to
somebody in mexico saying you know what
i'm i'm here and i'm trying to get to
the united states
so once they put this on you that means
let's say you already in the log books
basically
showing that you've already reported to
somebody if you
if you are from somewhere else and
you're here
in renosa for example and you don't have
this bracelet there could be different
options that might happen to you
they could kill you they could beat you
they could charge you a fine who's gonna
kill and beat the cartel
what what just there's a how many
cartels are there are there's different
ones but it depends who catches you
okay select for example i'm i'm from
jalisco mexico for example i come to
renosa
i'm in renosa and i'm trying to get to
the united states yeah
i'm trying to do it on my own yeah i
guess that's why no one does it on their
own
though the proper way they're supposed
to report to somebody whichever
cartel or whoever they report to
somebody
like i said they're logged in they're
all the information is put in so they're
able to know what's what
in this case like i said if it's like
i'm from uh i'm from jalisco and i'm in
renosa
i don't have this bracelet on yeah
they're gonna say who are you why are
you here
they're gonna question you and stuff and
like i said from there they could fine
you
for you know what we're gonna find you
so they might pick you up and hold you
hostage until that fine is paid
or they might beat you or something or
like you said worst the case scenario
they might kill you
because at the end of the day what
they're trying to tell these people
you're not going to do anything without
my permission you can't do anything
coming into this city
because you got to go through somebody
to be able to come into the united
states
i guess that answers the question from
the other day why they don't come
directly and walk on the bridge and
say i'm right here right to seek asylum
they have to go through a process
and it has to be recognized through that
through the different cartels do you
think
i don't want to go too too long in this
but cartels are intertwined with police
forces in different
uh regions of mexico or that's hard to
say okay
los cartelles policies
so what makes more money over the border
now drugs or people
wow so that's that's what people there's
more competition to get people over than
drugs
are huge
i asked him how much from jalisco mexico
for example to houston
yep he says he can't answer that
question
because he covers from reynosa to
houston renault
houston you you're gonna pay a total of
about nine thousand six hundred
whoa just from the north side of houston
but that's painting parts
like i said to cross the river so much
from uh
here to laredo so much from laredo to
houston to another amount or whatever
are there any times the cartels like let
someone it go without all the money and
then they
they sort of like have to make payments
i'm telling you you heard rumors yeah
morris
he says very few people that will
actually let you go without paying your
full
money at the final destination okay you
want for the simple reason
it's happened to him before where you
know what the promise to pay and
and they don't get paid so that's the
reason why by time we get to your final
destination
before they release you you're gonna pay
up what you owe okay
so guys i got one uh one last question
we'll stand out of the wind here
what does tony have to say about his
profession is there anything he wants
the world to know
exactly about him or his profession
[Music]
he's trying to say that you know at the
end of the day we're not all the same
yes i smuggle people
but you know what i'm not out doing
something wrong like other people might
be doing
as far as raping people selling people
stuff like so not everybody's the same
he doesn't want to be classified
as everybody else you know what he's not
smuggling kids okay he's not
doing stuff like that that he's not
supposed to he's just trying to help
somebody coming to the united states
because they want to come in
for whatever reason a better life for
whatever the reason might be okay
all right guys another another view of
the border region here between us
and mexico it's complicated there are a
lot of moving parts
and i'm trying to deliver you as many of
them as i can
it's getting dark thanks you guys thanks
for the translation no problem
and thanks tony for for being on camera
and telling your story
okay
all right that was quite interesting and
a first for me i'm sure
first for most of you and the point i do
this the point the reason why i'm doing
this is to bring you
into a different perspective a world
that you would normally not
get into and i'm not telling you to
agree
or disagree i am very much against
illegal immigration i'm not supporting
it here
what i am trying to do is show you that
this is a
a very complicated topic with a lot of
moving parts
and if you watch my full series i'm
trying to hit it from all different
angles an interesting interesting thing
about tony is
you know i'm thinking uh trafficker so
what comes to mind
sex trafficker guy with guns that likes
to kill people
and you know i do believe
you never know what goes up what what
someone is is really doing behind the
scenes but i
i do believe that he is moving people
from point a to point b
and that's his business and
he almost even had like a a soft side to
him in the car
uh you know and at first i was nervous
it was like you know
how often you hang out with traffickers
and you know what is this gonna be like
and it
and it was it was actually quite
surprisingly normal all of it and the
deeper i go into this rabbit hole this
border
migration rabbit hole the more
confusing and complicated and difficult
it gets you know you would need years
down here to really understand what's
going on but that's just a little taster
a little teaser and hopefully it opens a
discussion
it opens a different way of thinking
perhaps i know this is triggering
content
there's no way around that it's such a
hot topic i want to thank
the sponsorship of this video cuts this
t-shirt company
uh we found each other it's amazing
because i was looking for t-shirts for
like
two years a good one good one that
doesn't wear out quickly a good one
where the neck
stays together it breathes well and
takes this right now texas heat that i'm
in
i don't have to iron it it's legit
get one of these if you want a good
quality t-shirt
i got a link below a discount of 15
percent so if you click on my link you
get 15
off cuts t-shirts they also make
sweatshirts
and a few other things thanks for
watching this video
if this topic if you made it this far
you're probably into this topic so watch
the other ones
watch the other ones from the series
about the border
i had two more days here and i got three
more videos to make it's been
it's been a wild ride it's my head feels
like it's going to explode
a bit because of the amount of
information new information i've
received
thanks for coming along till the next
one take care
all right guys